Let's summarize the main points from the lecture.
When we take an image of a scene, it's a perspective
projection, and the depth information has
been lost.
Human beings use a number of tricks or visual
cues to reinstate that missing depth information.
The cue that we use depend on the circumstance
and also on the distance. Is it within our
personal space or is it out towards the horizon?
A particularly important technique that we
use, and so do many other animals, also it
will be used by robots is a technique called
binocular disparity. And that relies on the
small subtle changes between images of the
same scene taken from different vantage point.
Here's an example of a stereo image pair and
we can see between the left hand image and
the right hand image to correspond to what
we would see with our left eye and our right
eye. In general these two scenes look very
similar, but if we look more carefully there
is some subtle but important differences between
them, and it's these small subtle differences
that allows to extract information about this
three dimensional structure of the world.
Just as we have two eyes, we can build this
stereo camera which is a compact assembly
that contains effectively two independent
cameras and known distance of pi. An important
concept in stereovision is disparity. If we
identify a point in the left image and find
the same point in the right image it will
appear to have shifted somewhat to the left,
and that leftward shift we refer to as disparity.
Importantly, disparity is a function of distance.
So for an object that's close to us, there
is a large leftward shift, a large disparity,
where something that's far away has got a
smaller disparity.
So if we can make the disparity, then using
the geometry of stereovision, we can relate
the disparity to the distance to the object.
Use the two images to compute disparity, and
from that, then I can compute Z.
Computing disparity is not trivial. For every
pixel in the left hand image, I take a square
window of pixels surrounding it within search
for that same pattern of pixels in the right
hand image, and that involves making a lot
of image comparisons. It's the template-matching
problem that we looked at earlier.
So given a left image and a right image of
a scene, I can compute at every single pixel,
the disparity, and I can display that as a
disparity image or a disparity map, and in
a disparity map, things are bright if they're
near and they are darker if they are further
away. The converse is that if I have a stereo
pair, two images taken from slightly different
viewpoints, if I could present those images
to my left and right eye, I will have a very
vivid sense of the three dimensionality of
the scene, a very, very strong sense of depth.
Human beings have been fascinated with the
idea of 3D vision for a long, long time, and
we discussed an array of technologies, which
can perform this function.